hi everyone thanks for joining us today
and hopefully this click bTW title got
your attention a little bit more but
just to wake us up to take us extra mile
before lunch we'll do a quick crowd
survey if everybody could raise their
hand that's not very fun at first and
then if you can answer this question yes
put your hand down have you ever used
GrubHub ok good portion keep your hands
up although have you ever used food
delivery put your hand down oh oh how do
you like food everyone's hand is down so
and I think it's important when we talk
about technical things together that we
you know have some skin in the game so
it's interesting so we're wick so this
is relevant to all of us actually so
quick and I'll explain the Clady
tide a little bit but it's kind of a no
mosh to those goofy odds you see like
this weird trick this trainer did made
me lose 30 pounds or something you've
seen those on the Internet
so everyone knows our grub who is but
just be formal you know it's a it's a
platform that connects diners which are
all of you to take away restaurants in
your favorite city but it's also a three
sided marketplace because we have a
expansive delivery network so if you
know you get home from work one day
you're too tired to go out too tired to
cook pull up the GrubHub app and get the
food delivered to you here's some
typical flows that you interact with
GrubHub this is the app you pull it up
and the first thing you see is what we
call the default search this is
restaurant recommendations and this is
personalized so as you could see this is
my personal profile here I'm after some
promoted results you see actually a
personalized result because I had a lot
of French food and that is actually a
French restaurant the other way you can
interact with the group of course is
search so we want search to be both
exact and inexact as far as the text
matching goes so this will give you from
the query French we want semantic French
results so they prove a they Rivage but
also it came up with french fries so
semantic and exact matching once you
click on a restaurant this screen is
will get recommendations of menu items
and dishes on that restaurant and on
this page we see a list of cuisines so
you get kind of cuisine recommendations
too so I hope that it's clear from this
example that we're dealing in some
poram primitives in this GrubHub
universe namely restaurant dish cuisine
and menu and if you're working in
e-commerce company you want to
understand these things so maybe I could
highlight this issue a little more
clearly so imagine if you're starting a
business like GrubHub and you're
onboarding a bunch of restaurants so the
restaurants will put their menus on your
database and those menus are just kind
of unstructured they're plain text who
knows what they say they could not even
be food it could be advertisements or
something
my point is that this is unstructured
it's chaos in this graph here I have a
bunch of nodes but no edges there's
restaurants there's dishes
there's cuisines like Mediterranean also
missing from this graph our users users
are in there too and this is all
cluttered and we don't have an
understanding of it I couldn't give dish
recommendations I knew that you know a
certain menu item on a certain
restaurant is actually spanakopita for
example so and the catalog grows every
day its unbounded and it's unorganized
so any e-commerce company probably has
this dilemma so our goal is to go from
this chaos to some type of structure so
we can drive product demands and you can
imagine if we knew like that beef bulb
onion is a beef dish we can drive all
kinds of interesting product demand so
we can do trending dishes we can do
similar restaurants personalization
recommendation we could do semantic
search what's the popular taco
restaurants in New York and if you don't
have this these primitives the semantic
understanding of your catalogue it's
hard to drive this product request so
here's some that we're gonna look at and
explore I have I'm gonna come up like
five use cases so the first one where
can I get amazing blueberry pancakes the
second one what are some synonyms for
pierogi now pierogi actually has a lot
of different names in terms if you're
curious um a simple rule based matching
search system would have very bad recall
show me French restaurants in Brooklyn
we have lots of restaurants and GrubHub
in Brooklyn but how do we know what they
are what are the top ten Asian noodle
dishes near me how do we know that Ann
Arbor
cherri menu item in the GrubHub universe
is first of all a noodle dish and second
of all even Asian and then how do we
make the top ten training ones find me
French restaurants that I like so don't
just find me like French restaurants
which might be easy with you know naive
text matching find ones that are
personalized towards me tailored towards
me so the goal of doing this will help
us build what we're calling kind of like
the grub pub food universe and this
latent knowledge graph and the jokes
over the tricks over the weird trick is
representational anger so we were
talking a lot about embeddings today and
we have three entry projects that we
worked on independently the first one's
called query Tyvek the second one is
called restavek and the third one is
called menu to Vic they're sorry fast
menu Emily and those respectively model
users restaurants and menus and those
three things make up you know the
Trinity of the grub pub universe I guess
so the first one I'm gonna talk to you
today is a project I worked on and it's
called query to vex so to understand
query Tyvek we're gonna need a little
bit of background on information
retrieval namely the grub hub search
pipeline so when you type French and -
grub up for example the first thing we
do is you try to do some normalization
to that query we remove any punctuation
whitespace weird characters and then we
do intent classification on it so we try
and figure out you know is this a dish
cuisine or restaurant query after that
we want to do something called query
expansion so we go into this query
building phase so the goal of this is to
make our queries more general so here's
the problem if I'm in a small town in
Barstow California where I grew up and
there's maybe like one Asian restaurant
and it's called Panda Express if I type
Dandan noodles into GrubHub it's not
gonna find anything but if we're able to
generalize this Chinese spicy noodle
dish and to maybe just Asian then the
search engine can show me something so
there's a business requirement I comes
in the case here like do you want to
show nothing or do you want to show
something when easier types a tail query
or in a small market now imagine another
case I'm in a big city like New York and
we type in pierogies but pierogies have
like five different names
what do we do do we shoot nothing or do
we generalize this query into samosas
maybe whatever query is or we can maybe
look up another word like a balloons so
that's the motivation for doing query
expansion and I actually have here so
here's the Dandan noodles I'd you and
this is a theoretical expansion that
doesn't exist you know it's a perfect
system if we could do this then we can
expand that to spicy noodles Chinese
maybe even Japanese an Asian so as you
can see we kind of Traverse this virtual
food graph here now if I was in the you
know Barstow California in my hometown
I'd at least get Panda Express results
if I was in New York I'd get Dandan
noodles and the effect of this in
information retrieval literature is we
get increased recall we get something
instead of nothing and that's the goal
of this early stage in the search
pipeline is to have as many relevant
results as possible and then we'll prune
them down later in ranking so let's look
at some examples how query expansion has
been done in the past and what we're
proposing to do with this solution so
classical query expansion is typically
done with some type of a thesaurus
looking up synonyms so let's continue
with that dan dan noodles example we
were to throw that into a thesaurus what
would come up I don't know if we can
look up dan dan it's like a proper noun
it's not even English maybe we can throw
noodles at it but unfortunately that
would come up with cranium brain noggin
and thinker which is a side-effect of
the English language and noodles being
just being another term for the brain so
this might be a contrived example but
hopefully it illustrates the case that
you know doing these thesaurus
expansions especially in certain domains
could have pretty bad precision a better
way an ideal way to do this is to have a
knowledge graph I showed you one on the
last slide
here's another pretend one for this dan
dan noodles example if we have this
theoretical perfect knowledge graph here
the expansion is pretty easy you just
traverse the graph you can go up and say
Chinese and go down and say noodles you
can even go say Asian and then you can
service the query with high recall
whether you're in a small market or
whether it's a very obscure tail query
however
the bit outside of the scope of this
talk but building a knowledge graph like
this is not trivial
I'm sure if you work an e-commerce
company maybe you've had some type of
initiative grab definitely has an
initiative to build knowledge graphs
sometimes they're done by just like
human armies doing labeling things like
I know some competitors in the space
have just people tagging items every
time they come in this is a dish this is
a cuisine this is a chicken dish this is
a noodle dish this is French food and
that might work if you want to keep
throwing money I like that other way to
do it are to make a bunch of rule-based
systems
hopefully my point is that these are
difficult to build scale maintain and
expensive so we're looking at a way to
do it with this huge trove of behavioral
data GrubHub has so people come onto our
platform every day and huge magnitudes
of numbers and type things in the
GrubHub french food and they'll click on
a French restaurant going back to this
dan dan noodles example people will come
in to grub up and type dan dan noodles
and they'll convert on a Szechuan
restaurant people will come in type Mapo
tofu Mapo tofu and convert on that same
shesh on restaurant other people's will
type Chinese and cover on that Chinese
restaurant and the goal is that if we
can cluster enough of these similar
queries around they're converting
restaurants will be able to have a
cluster of similar queries and that is
taking inspiration from the word Tyvek
architectures which were naming queried
avec so with or devic you embed words
it's a language model what if we can
instead of doing a language model what
if we can do a query model what if we
can embed queries and then we can just
do nearest-neighbor in this query space
and do a query expansion so if someone
typed in dan dan noodles I look up that
dan dan noodles embedding and just your
simple nearest neighbor look up and find
similar items to it at least that's in
theory it would happen and that would be
equivalent it's reversing this graph so
here's how we do it I'm like I mentioned
this just taking inspiration from the
word to that class of models and in
particular this is the skip Ram
architecture and this is a Python carpet
so I thought we'd look at some Python
code and some data so here is the main
thing we want this is the bigquery
embedding since I've dan dan noodles on
the saw French we didn't
and if we actually learned the the
correlation between the restaurant and
the converted item will actually do
interesting things with those embeddings
this is the output betting this is the
classical vocabulary you hear about in a
word Tyvek architecture we take these
query embeddings through the dot product
with the softmax and then we just
optimized using categorical cross
entropy um oftentimes you'll see it's
called like product effect or something
like that just a generalization of the
word Tyvek using the distributive
hypothesis where in this case instead of
making pairs of words that are close
together in the sentence we're making
pairs of queries and converted
restaurants and this is very low-level
tensorflow code query embedding is at
the top the soft knock weights up there
we take the logit which is just the
matrix multiply between the selected
embedding and the label and then you
have two choices here the the
theoretical way to do is you can do
softmax on it but this is a data
conference we have a lot of data maybe
you know that the softmax loss doesn't
scale and your vocabulary gets maybe
passed like 10,000 so 1 over the scale
is up to what we do we do a year of
queries which is millions of millions of
queries we have to approximate that
softmax
and we do that using NCE or any other
type of approximation so yeah like I
said we do about a year of queries we
make pairs of queries and converter
restaurants we train it using tensor
flow the Python API and we do heavily
pre-processing normalization on the
queries using high spark on an EMR
cluster and I can get through a year of
data one epoch in about 15 minutes on a
Amazon p2 which is a pretty old GPU that
shows that I'm kind of the scale we're
working with so enough about I guess the
code and the theory let's actually look
at some results so we all know this is
unsupervised algorithm there's no sure
quantitative way to evaluate its quality
if you have one we'd love to discuss
that but when we look at the quality of
these bangs is actually looking at up
and doing example expansions so a nice
way to do that if you're the tentacle
ecosystem is the embedding projector so
you can put your embeddings into this
software from google and it'll show you
the embedding
in three-dimensional space it also has a
nice little widget that you do nearest
neighbor look up so here's that so let's
look at some examples look at for
examples and look at the quality of
these embeddings user goes to grub bub
and for some reason they search alcohol
now imagine if you're building a search
engine like if you had chat
elasticsearch for example you know a
nice common piece of instruction
infrastructure people used for search if
you put alcohol in there and you did a
lexical matching you might not find
anything because menu items would
probably not be named alcohol like
they're named wine beer Corona like
different types of alcohol so here's
what the expansion's are like I said
wine beer Corona red wine and also you
see things called grocery store and
grocery items and that's an artifact of
the behavioral data so typically when
people buy alcohol and GrubHub it's from
a bodega so you see some similar things
from the bodega interesting there so
this will instantly increase your recall
on your search system now the next
example is a cuisine so in this case the
user typed in Italian the first thing
you guys Maggiano's that's a restaurant
a second thing we get is vongole we get
Pomodoro which is string that's the tie
in word for tomato we can yoki rigatoni
carbonara
ketchup epic so if you can imagine like
the theoretical Italian food graph it
would look like that you'd have a tie
and then you'd have these dishes but
also this embedding is multimodal we
don't just have dishes in there we don't
just have menu items we actually have
restaurants in there too so that
increases search recall which is the
goal the third example let's look at a
dish a ramen dish I'm a the cool thing
here is that it shows the the robust
nature of this technique is that the
first result is ramen but it's
misspelled so of course if you have a
search system you want it to be robust
in the Spelling's and this is just a
product of data people for some reason
often misspelled ramen maybe it's
autocorrect but it shows it from the
data and we're able to account for it
and correct for it that instantly
reduces recall of our system and of
course see all different varieties of
ramen
the fourth example is my favorite
because I lived in Korea but you
actually type in a Korean dish in
romanized Korean kimchi chigae which is
a stew made of kimchi you get all these
results back that are semantic of course
you get Korean Korean barbecue or you
get these other dishes that are
romanized Korean like kabhi Tong chopped
J bibimbap bulgogi milk Jack kimchi stew
called B and these are all Korean dishes
so very powerful I think there's there's
not just I hope I just want to highlight
there's not simple lexical string
matching here like there's a higher
understanding of what the query is and
that leads to increased we call so to
close my part of the talk I just want to
share two more examples because I keep
talking about this this late in food
graph here's one I found from the
internet a reference graph you know
there's no true graph I guess and then I
put that into I put a random note from
this graph dieudonné into the nearest
neighbors and as you could see from the
nearest neighbors and the annotations I
drew that we essentially recover this
food graph I think that's pretty
compelling qualitative result um one
more with a different subset of the food
graph Mediterranean here so we have this
theoretical perfect food graph of the
some Mediterranean subset and as you can
see from all my annotations we recover
this food graph from the behavioral data
without actually doing any human or
rule-based
knowledge graph building so I will close
my section now and just either
summarizing a point that now this was
query Tyvek and we were doing it to
understand the user a little bit better
user in their queries so that's one
important part of the GrubHub universe
now the second important part which
parent is going to talk about next is
the restaurants so
so hello everyone my name is Pauline and
I'm going to cover this model called
estwick so where does this model fit
into our ecosystem is we highlighted
that it's a personalization so we want
to serve users a personalized restaurant
recommendation and just in the same team
as Alex mentioned we are creating the
embeddings for behave from behavioral
data for query we are going to create a
embeddings for restaurants from the
behavior data as well so restavek is
just creating a numerator numerical
vector representation of restaurants
data from our clickstream blocks using
users click and conversion and how does
it gonna help it's going to help us
understand a large catalog of
restaurants that we have at kebab and it
empowers discovery and personalization
again it's an adaptation of a very
famous what to work algorithm again Alex
give you the introduction what it does
and it has some striking similarity in
which we want to do with the restaurants
so we are saying that how we move from
were to back to restavek and both in the
data and algorithm parlance it has some
similarity between what do I can dress
to it so we'll go with that and see how
it makes sense to create this model so
in natural language processing is what
to work is a very famous algorithm
starting this decade a lot of downstream
model lot of downstream and into models
got a good accuracy using word
embeddings and that typically the input
to the model is a each training row is a
sentient each training row is a sequence
of tokens coming out of a sentence and
if the training if we provide enough
training rows and love and Chinese are
you know in a same example so many times
we say that semantically love and
Chinese have some relationship we we go
to the information retrieval system
and we replace the sequence of tokens
which sequence of restaurants and
contacts from sentence to user session
and we have a we have a word to work
converted into the into the rest work or
the product way the only thing here is
what is the session so session is an
intent full session from the user so
user types in a pizza we present user
some list of restaurants user clicks on
restaurant one restaurant two and
convert on restaurant three so this
makes a this makes a session for us and
we know that this restaurant one two and
three do share some commonality in terms
of pizza because user has a user has a
strong intent and he converted on one of
this restaurant
so token of words are replaced by
sequence of restaurants the context was
sentence but now the context is a
session so these are these are some
parallels between what two wagon rest
work and the data and this is a famous
distributional hypothesis that a word is
cactus by the company it keeps we are
saying the restaurant is character by
the company keeps the next is the
algorithm how the algorithm is exactly
the same architecture is exactly the
same only the data semantics is
different on left-hand side were to a
queen put sequence of tokens try to
predict the next token as a soft mix as
output layer which exactly the same
algorithm which alex used for query to
work and we get output embeddings from
the softmax layer which which are
embeddings for all the restaurants so we
move from what to wagon rest to work s
to act takes and input as a session and
restaurant ideas in a session and we
predict the next restaurant so very
tight coupling between between dark
attack choice it's exactly the same
actually it's not a different this is a
Python code
we use a jensen model Jen seems what to
work model to train it it's pretty much
summarized to everything this is the
entire model other than the data
pre-processing part we use a spark to do
the data pre-processing and then train
the model using the Jen sims over to
work implementation all the hyper
parameters are similar to what to work
we just modify that to work well with
our domain which is restaurant
similarity a bit stats about a training
data we had about 60 million session on
which we train it takes about an hour to
train a complete model on 16 million
data points we do filter out the
sessions sessions must be intentful in a
sense that they all should have a query
because of our hypothesis is like if
user is querying something and trying to
search for something he has a strong
intent so we don't get a we don't get a
noisy
data set we will limit the length of the
session for for restaurant to eat
restaurant per session we don't want to
use a too short session because we won't
learn anything we don't want to use very
large session because user might show
some random behavior
he might search for something and just
clicking window-shopping doing something
we just want to remove that so that's an
important piece of the algorithm and why
we get a good results on that will which
which I'll share in a second and we have
about 140 thousand restaurants in the
training data set that we generate the
empirics for again we use a tensor board
visualization train the model loaded
embeddings into tens about visualization
this is a very bird eye view of tea Snee
algorithm which is embedded into tensile
tensile or visualization so each point
in this 2d graphic is is a restaurant
and
[Music]
we can we can clearly see some semantics
in the cluster so we we do see cluster
for each different states New York
Arizona Florida Colorado Massachusetts
these are the restaurants in the same
same location which is which is very
important for for our business because
we don't want to search if user is in
California we don't want to search a
restaurant in New York and vice versa
and it also captures the size like
market size these cluster size is
proportional to the number of
restaurants that we have in specific
market some more example of nearest
neighbor we just did the similar
approach which Alex mentioned earlier
for query Tuvok is like on the top on we
have a query restaurant and here the
list of similar restaurant to that
restaurant a pretty cool thing that we
can observe is like the input restaurant
is a takeout pizza place all of the
neighbors are also the similar type of
restaurant we didn't put any of such
information it's just a byproduct of
using the behavioral data you can see
that all the restaurants are in New York
City they also shared a pretty similar
zip code this is also pretty important
for our business because say this brow
is eyes your go-to place it's closed you
cannot order from it we can show you
some alternates which are in in a
cuisine and in type and style it matches
with your query restaurant and it's also
in a very very same geo graphical
location so they would probably order
you the like they would deliver you
deliver you the food in about the same
time which is one of the very important
thing for our business there is example
in the middle which is a mixed cuisine
example where the query restaurant is a
type of Indian cuisine as well as a
Nepali squeezed in but Indianism primary
cuisine so top few neighbors for that
restaurant also share the similar
semantics and typically we don't see
that many in Dorne Poly's restaurant in
any marketplace so once it fades out
that if
we can see that other like it falls back
on a primary cuisine of your query
restaurant so we got this result without
inputting any like without and
engineering any of the features it just
a byproduct of what we get from the
behave data and the last one is a not a
restaurant it's a grocery shop and it
does sell a food but it's also sell the
grocery items so you can see all the
nearest neighbors are very similar
typically they have a long menu they
sell alcohol and stuff like that none of
the features again a hand engineer in
just by product of behavioral data where
people are clicking and searching this
slide shows how we capture our the new
embeddings so every day grab up adds a
lot of restaurants nearly and as it
comes to our search system as it gets
exposed to the search system people
start clicking on it we start to get
increase coverage on the restaurants and
this is there's a last slide we are we
I'm showing you the some data flow graph
for how we implemented this in a service
how we integrated this into service
so typically typically they're two to
portion offline and online in offline we
use a high and spark a lot to do the
data pre-processing creating a training
data side and all and once that's done
we train the model offline using gen sim
which is also a Python package we export
our train model on s3 online system will
pick up these embeddings and load into a
enoy index which is also Python package
for doing the fast nearest-neighbor
which is very important portion in the
online thing because we don't want to
wait for it to a long time for for
serving the recommendation so it's a low
latency software package which can
compute the nearest neighbors in
milliseconds so it's an important piece
in online infrastructure user comes in
we look at user comes in with their past
orders pastoral has restaurants we look
the restaurants finest restaurants build
a recommendation and so do their users
so they say this is restavek and next in
the same team and we will present fast
menu thank you all right so I'll try and
talk fast so we have time for questions
which will then generate questions
because I'm talking really fast so the
next step in this we've gone over
restaurants and understanding what our
users once we want to then connect to
actual menu items you don't eat a
restaurant you don't eat a delivery you
eat some actual food so we've looked at
a couple of the models that work with
word Tyvek in terms of behavioral
features now we're gonna look at
actually content based features so
instead of a user determining what these
things are about we're gonna have
somebody who wrote a description about a
menu item and this is gonna help with
our semantic matching during candidate
selection so we know what you want and
maybe which restaurants they should come
from the question then is gonna be which
actual dish should be surfaced and we're
gonna call this fast menu instead of
menu two Veck because I like that name
better so what we're doing is create a
numerical vector representation that we
can use in downstream use cases of our
menu items based on the text that's
actually surrounding them there's no
behavioral data in this so this helps
with our menus and like we said with
semantic search and the great thing
about this is that we get total coverage
of everything in our catalog because it
isn't behavioural we're able we don't
have to wait for somebody to click on it
before or for somebody to search for
something we have all that data if it
exists we can do a prediction on this
and there's trade-offs between
behavioral and content based data
because somebody could just make up
something they could write a really bad
description they could have a null
string we can't do any prediction with
that that's a downside of content-based
of content-based
prediction methods but you get
everything the downside of behavioral is
you have to wait for somebody to click
on something so in general there's
always this trade-off between which of
these two methods do you use or do you
wait them have some combination thereof
in our system I've been working under
if it ain't broke don't fix it so fast
menu works on content there's definitely
ways to incorporate behavior on this as
well and again to just highlight the
benefits of semantic matching if we have
two examples my foon and blueberry
pancake we can see if we go straight
with a string or fuzzy matching for my
foon you end up with things that are
similar to my phone and for blueberry
pancakes it's something that its name is
not in a foreign language it describes
exactly what it is it's a pancake with
some blueberries so you get a blueberry
smoothie which is a smoothie that has
some blueberries or buttermilk pancake
those are options that could maybe be
similar the trouble with my phone is
that's not an English language name it's
a name that's adopted from something
else and doesn't actually describe
anything to me I wouldn't know what my
phone is if I just saw that name and the
way that gets represented on menu items
in the u.s. is often stir-fried noodles
or thin rice noodles so you're missing
all of those if you don't use a semantic
matching and even in the blueberry
pancake place option which is very
descriptive the Grand Slam breakfast
from Denny's comes with blueberry
pancakes but you'd be missing that
information as well
so using one of these models you get
increased recall for people to pick from
and as we have seen many times this is
based on a word to Veck architecture but
the difference in the behavioral models
where you're doing things to Veck is
that those are those are not language
models we're actually using a language
model fast text that is a child of words
effect that instead of using words as
your atomic unit it uses sub word
strings so where we have pizza is no
longer the atomic unit it is we would
say these two character length strings
so PII zza and you'd be predicting the
next element this is a difference
between words avec and fast text a big
benefit of this is you can do out of
vocabulary predictions so if we haven't
seen a word before we don't throw an
error when we do the prediction you can
say okay I haven't seen cheese pizza
before but I have seen CH and yes and
you can aggregate
those two get a prediction so you don't
have to train all of the time it's
computationally nicer on your resources
and then in terms of text what actually
is the text that you should use with
menu item there's a gajillion ways to
format this pick the ones that you like
what we went with was taking the name
the menu item description and we
actually decided to keep restaurant
cuisines for the cases where we all know
that tacos from a breakfast only
restaurant probably has a scrambled eggs
base but that information is nowhere in
any of the name or description if it's
just tacos if you include breakfast as a
cuisine then you can get a stronger
signal so we keep the restaurant
cuisines we reject the restaurant names
because they don't have any useful
information reviews you get a lot of
three out of five which is super noisy
it's possible to incorporate them we
chose not to so we have great
characterizing text but we don't have
any location awareness I don't know that
San Janeiro's Pizza is in Dobbs Ferry
and it doesn't make sense for me to
order it if I live in Brooklyn that
information is missing and if we look
back at parens restavek we saw these
really nice location bias clusters which
helps support our KN nearest neighbors
so you can do real-time predictions we
don't want to predict a menu item in San
Francisco for somebody ordering from New
York so the ability to do this location
is important so then we come to
geohashes geo hashing it's dividing up
the surface of the earth into a series
of rectangles and squares these are
continuous they're represented by
alphanumeric strings the exact same one
used in the English language and all the
characters that we have on our platform
some things to notice about them is
they're sequential so nine q8y
is next to nine q8w
and also their precision level gets
nested inside so dr5 z is inside dr v
which is inside dr so basically what we
have is these sub words string
give information in the way that Inge is
usually associated with a verb like
running well we now have 9q is
associated with san francisco
whereas dr is associated with New York
so we can use geohashes
to act as location words and further
just to have words if we take a
restaurant and then traverse through all
the geohashes around it that has a
specific ordering and if you do the
traversal in the same path every time
now you're ordering you can use this as
a sentence the position of Geo hash
words in relation to one another has
meaning in the same way that grammar
should have a structure so we actually
just take our geo hash sentence we stick
it on the end of our text sentence and
now we have a location aware text
document so then we go ahead and do our
fast text embedding and this is your
quick data side just order of magnitude
about 10 million menu items we're using
an embedding dimension of 30 because
people describe things with the same
words all of the time so going back to
our tensor board visualization we have
TCE and PCA just to look at kind of the
quality of things and for those of you
who are colorblind
I did not pick these colors but this
cluster is Topeka and this one is
Nashville so what we're seeing we picked
three markets of varying sizes that are
physically separated from each other we
can see that Phoenix is separated from
Topeka which is separated from Nashville
and we're going to conclude from that
that our location-aware
text embeddings worked to give us a
location bias we can also see that
Topeka is physically closer to Nashville
than it is to Phoenix which is
geographically true as well and if we
look at the local features we can
actually see that within a specific
market they tend to cluster around
cuisines
so in Phoenix you have at large Mexican
food cuisine an Asian and an Indian food
Nashville has an Asian cuisine
and Topeka which is a small market
everything is clustered around itself
because it doesn't have that many
restaurants so we conclude our location
embedding works so quickly we'll look at
some nearest neighbors skip this guy but
if we see thin rice noodle tray I know
this is my foon because I have ordered
this dish in Nashville and things that
it recommends are pork my phone trip my
phone chicken my phone vegetable my
phone we're picking up the semantic
elements there if we look at the grande
nachos from Taco Bell case there are
eight taco bells in a 40 mile radius so
there's no chance for a semantic
matching it's like there's so many
grande nacho Box options that's what
you're getting we're not excluding that
from our list and then finally with 37
beef the description of that is comes
with white rice so we're not getting a
lot of semantic information from the
description but it's from Beijing
Chinese which is an Asian restaurant so
all the restaurants that it's
recommending and the dishes come from
Asian restaurants as well so we're
getting semantics as well as location
bias in this and quickly just throw up
some of the packages that we use Jenn
Simon fast XR pretty standard our
feature engineering is done in pice Park
and to do the geo hashing we needed to
use all three of these packages and
they're the slow piece here so now that
we understand diners and restaurants and
menu items we can answer the really
important question like where are you
gonna eat at lunch after this so if
there's any questions you'll have to
wait until afterward because I used all
of our time and thanks
[Applause]